[Musique]
la première étape du déconfinement
enclenchée depuis le 3 mai fin de la
limitation des 10 km et de l'attestation
de déplacement des professionnels
regardent désormais vers le 19 mai date
de la réouverture des terrasses des
lieux culturels et des commerces fermés
la campagne de vaccination s'accélère
emmanuel macron a annoncé l'ouverture
aux plus de 50 ans et surtout la
possibilité désormais pour les plus de
18 ans de recevoir une injection
lorsqu'il reste des doses de vaccin pour
ne pas les gâcher a dit le chef de
l'état
l'hommage rendu par les pompiers à leurs
collègues à la caserne de rambouillet le
caporal justin almeida 19 ans s'est tué
à moto le 30 avril
il devait participer au dispositif de
sécurité de l'hommage national rendu à
la fonctionnaire de police stéphane ils
ont fermé les élections départementales
sont au programme les 20 et 27 juin
prochains et les candidats aux scrutins
sont désormais connus dans les yvelines
91 binôme paritaire sont en lice dans
les 21 cantons du département 120
joueurs sur le parcours de l'albatros le
linxea open se tient jusqu'au 8 mai au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
la particularité du tournoi mais les
golfeurs amateurs et professionnels
enfin cette année c'est le bicentenaire
de la mort de napoléon bonaparte il
s'était éteint le 5 mai 1821 sur l'île
de sainte hélène
le château de versailles possède l'une
des plus importantes collections
napoléonienne 400 tableaux et 200
sculptures dédiée à celui qui fut
empereur de france
[Musique]
pas